oil in here. And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call. We have a number of questions that came
in. And we do have to address if you are a true RIFE emailist, the critical update version 6.4.
Touched on it last week, but have more details this week and more details on your member site.
So make sure you use your member site for now. We'll see some information on there that you'll
want to utilize here from people. We literally hear from people every week that haven't been on
the member site for even a year. You know, it's like, well, I don't know, I don't understand. So
please use the member site. Please, if you want a coaching call, you can pay for the coaching call
on the member site. You can schedule fill out this request form on the member site as well.
Really important that keeps us protected. And it saves us time on that coaching call because I know
what you want to talk about. So fill that out on the member site that coaching call request form.
Please do that. You know, you have access to all the courses and the blooms. And now let's talk
about the true RIFE update. I've created a video here, play here because I just embedded the picture,
but you can look at the member site. It's on the homepage and on the right page of the member site.
So look at that video about the true RIFE software update to help you understand whether you need to
do that or not. Also created a data there and written for it. So it says do not update to RIFE program
to 6.4 and tell you watch the above video. That's this video that I created. So please watch that video.
If you do or already did update to 6.4, you will not see your personal programs. So if you update to
program 6.4 software, your personal programs go bye bye. So you don't want to do that without
be careful in doing some other steps first. These are the other steps you have to make sure that you
have saved your program before you're okay. But if you already did the update and your programs are gone,
okay, well then you're going to have to either send your computer back to us or if you feel like
you're really computer savvy, we could send your program flash drive and you could follow these
instructions. They're not going to go over here. They're on the member site,
two pages on the member site, the homepage of the member site, and on the RIFE page they're also on
the right frequency course. So you can look at them there. This walks you through when I have to do
if you send your computer back to me and if you already updated to 6.4. So go ahead and look at those
with 6.4, even with 6.1, 6.2, which not very many of you have, but with anything over 6.0, which 99%
of you have, you have two extra clicks. It's just two extra clicks. It's not that big a deal.
It is two extra clicks and that's not going to go away anytime soon. You have to follow two extra
things. You have to open up the open home, open program of your true rights. Then you have to go to my
doc to documents on the left hand side and the documents you'll see a folder that says two right
frequencies that either you or I created. And in there you'll see your personal program. And if you're
still running 6.0, you're wondering what in the world I'm talking about. Well, you have to watch
this video to understand it. So no more time on that. Questions. Most of my life I've had dry skin on
my hands. If I didn't use lotion often enough, I would have stamping paint in addition to the dryness.
Now I have itchy dry skin with stamping paint all over my body. That has been torturing me for
three months. In a telephone conversation about a month ago, I think you mentioned that itching
is common with lymphomas. I don't want to take the pharmaceutical medications to trade it. I've
tried multiple lotions and natural remedies. 100% coconut oil is the only thing that brings
some relief when applied, but it doesn't do enough. I paid discomfort is constantly a six out of 10.
It goes as high as nine out of 10 in my worst moments when my body temperature changes.
Do you know anything safe for my body that could help my pain? Also, the flavor of the food is not
the same as the aroma I'm smelling. This seems so strange to me. I'm taking at least 50 micrograms
of zinc daily for weeks without noticing any improvement. I'm any thoughts on how to remedy this.
Well, there's a couple possibilities that are going on with this flavor and the food thing.
And I have to do a little bit more investigation to answer that question.
As far as the itchiness and the dry skin that you've had most of your life,
I'm sure if you already were prone to that for reasons that I'll have to think about for a few
minutes here, and then you end up with the phoma on top of that, which quite often can cause that.
It's it's an exasperated symptoms that even most lymphoma patients would have.
I'm sorry for that. As far as dealing with the original, the person just calls that I just have
dry skin, what can you do about it? It's really an internal problem. It's not an external problem.
It is not, you know, yes, it can be caused from external things. Let's say you're using
your using chemicals on your skin because you wash parts in a part clean air because you're a
mechanic or something and you don't use gloves and you're getting chemicals and damaging your skin.
And that's what's causing dry skin. But when you have dry skin, typically without any exposure
to exogenous sources of that that would damage your skin and your external epithelial cells,
you think of internal things. So it quite often has to do with an inability to break down
fatty acids. If that's covered more covered than you think that has to do with issues with
dermatitis and stuff like that too, they have a lack of ability to break down fatty acids and fatty
acids are necessary to lubricate your, your dermis layers. So doing things
topically can be helpful as far as like what you're saying. You're using coconut oil. I would also
think of some alarm-based creams that might be helpful for you. But you do want to address it
internally, like increasing, trying, you know, a high DHA, EPA, you know, trying some good different
variety of visual supplements. I would try that as well. So I have to think about this a little
bit. I want to have a conversation about this. I said to blood work to liver enzymes went down.
So that's a good side, but the alkaline phosphate went up a lot. So let's think about that a little
bit. So elevated liver enzymes almost invariably speak to damage to the liver via, you know,
toxin exposure or metastasis to the liver. Alkaline phosphate alkaline phosphatase is
considered a liver enzyme, but it also will elevate, so it'll elevate if there's damage to the liver.
But it will also go up if there's metastasis to the bone, which your other liver enzymes won't.
So if you have normal liver enzymes with elevated alkaline phosphatase,
then you think of is there metastasis to the bone. So in this case, if your liver enzymes went down,
that means we're detoxing much better. If your alkaline phosphatase went up,
that just as an indication of where we already know in this person's case is that there's metastasis
to the bone, doesn't mean that there's more metastasis per se, but that's why it's going up.
Trying to do as many coffee animals as possible a day, and that's what's probably helping detox
the liver and helping with the liver enzymes catch the wrong path,
along with everything else. Started radiation on Monday on rip, any ideas.
I did start Heliboros mistletoe last week, just half the dose. So understand there's two different
types of mistletoe that is used in mistletoe therapy. The Heliboros is the second type that
can be very beneficial if the person's doing radiation. So I'm glad that your doctor is doing
well with that protocol. I'm not sure if the alkaline phosphatase went up after the radiation or not.
It's going to be interesting to see how radiation therapy changes the alkaline phosphatase levels.
I have a few questions. Can I go to the dentist and get treatment health-delete? Is it dangerous?
I know I have cavities that possibly root canals need it. So first of all, I wouldn't get any root
canals personally. It's hard to do that if it's a front tooth or something like that, but
there's just dangers in getting root canals. I think I have some articles on the blog post
so you can certainly Google lots of dangers in root canals articles out there by good biological
dentists. If a person, if you're fairly healthy, you know, you're not like super, super sick with
your cancer, certainly you should go to the dentist and you should get your teeth cared for.
You should go try your best to go to a biological dentist who will not even recommend root canals,
so find a biological dentist in your area would be my first choice because you want to get proper
dentistry, not just regular dentistry. Can I take soures up leaves to boil to make tea?
I don't know the answer to that. Honestly, I don't know. I've not ever done that. I've not had
anybody do that, not anybody tell me that they were doing that, so I do not know the answer to that.
It's really good at getting rid of cancer. Yeah, I don't, I wish I'll do some investigation
if I don't know. Can I, yeah, or is this pushing it for me? No, Yams has a very low glycemic index,
so you'd be fine eating seeds. That would be fine. That would be a good source of some calories.
I've been able to get a supply of Ivermectin. What would you suggest for Dosey,
and how long for prostate cancer? Excuse me, well, Ivermectin is a prescription drug, so I can give
you too much details on that except that there's a lot of data out there that they have been covering
upsets, COVID stuff about the benefits of Ivermectin for cancer. As far as what I have read at least,
I have any negatives really. There isn't really any downsides to that, so I don't see any downsides
to doing it. I would certainly try it if it was me, so I would give it a try for sure. I was not
expecting blood work done today after radiation. I think they will do weekly blood work since
the chemotherapy raises glucose levels. My alkaline foscubes going up. I've been on this chemotherapy
for 10 days. This pill makes me so hungry. I could eat anything in sight yet. I am swelling up,
and I can't eat much at a time. I'm trying too fast, but I wake up so hungry at night,
see the new oncologist tomorrow. I'm not sure what she will say about the adema thought maybe that
the laboris mistletoe might help. I'm excited to hear if you see that this helps. We've had some
other people that have used that while they're doing radiation with some good success. From my last
cheek swab you suggested a mycotox test. The mycotox test is the name of the test from mosaic
laboratories used to be great claims laboratories and a test for glyphosate. So mosaic has a good
glyphosate test too. I like those two tests. Would it be better to get the vibrant america total
tox burden organic acid pfa's test for more overall information? There's pros. Personally there's
pros and cons to the organic acid test. Me, I think the negative to the organic acid test is I think
the information that's gleaned from that changes on a daily basis. So I think this is a less beneficial
test. I know there's a lot of functional doctors that have their hand on organic acid testing, but
I'm not one of them. I don't think it's a super valuable test. The total tox burden. I'm not sure
about vibrant america's total tox burden test. So sure we've had people get other tests. You want to
get that test. You can do that for sure. We'll look at that. My tissue pathology from my double
mastectomy came back with a tasticis to my left sent to the node and two of five other nodes
on the left. My surgeon took what she's not was one node. We couldn't pre surgery, but it was cloned
together. She wants me to consult with the ecologists see if the nodes need to be removed or
if we do radiation. I'm supposed to consult with the radiologist tomorrow.
In a new oncologist on Monday, I keep reading negative things about radiation. Plus the plastic surgeon
said radiated skin causes complications with implants, which I plan on right now. I will consult
with you one and one after again. There's some more information. But can you think of anything? I
should be considering and asking these docs as I gather information. Well, as you know, in other
conversations that we've had in the zoom calls, I'm not a huge fan of some tissue radiation,
unless it can be really targeted. So yeah, I would say wait until you have another conversation with
the ecologists and then we could talk. If you didn't recommend any after surgery supplements,
when you did my cheek swab, does that mean I didn't need any extra healing? The answers, that's
correct. So let me finish a question here because they did a dipole graph and it seems to be healing okay,
but one side is not as good as the other. I have a good, I have a bit of garden of life grass
spent college and peptides, but it has 1900 milligrams of quantumic acid for 20 grams of scoop.
So I didn't know if that'd be a good or not, whereas there's something else I could use.
So a lot of the supplements that a person would take to try to heal faster after a surgery
are supplements that are going to stimulate cell growth. That's why it helps you heal faster
after a surgery. So is it wise for a cancer patient to be taking a bunch of supplements that will
stimulate cell growth? Well that's a question you have to ask yourself, but my book is probably not
the wisest thing to do. So that's why I do typically recommend taking after surgery supplements to
help a person feel unless it's a surgery that has a person's neck diagnosed with cancer. So I would
not, I would not recommend this product that I would recommend taking other products to help you heal faster.
I got a rash on day eight post chemo and still haven't now on day 13. It's very itchy and sore
covers 90% of me. Oh my goodness. Are you familiar with rashes from chemo? So yes, it's very common
to get rashes from chemo. They have different syndromes that they've called it.
Handed foot disease or something like that because your body is you're detoxeted and you get a
reaction. So there's different thoughts to why you get rashes after chemo. Is it your body detoxing
through the skin? And that's causing the rash. Is it because you're basically having an allergic
histamine type reaction to the chemo? That's a possibility. So number one, is there something I could
have done to prevent it? Not really. No. Did I detox not enough? Or maybe too much? Her
shy, herxymer reaction. The answer is no, that's not a herxymer reaction. So herxymer reaction is
a reaction to cell death where you have endotoxins and you're reacting to endotoxins typically
like a polysaccharide. So that's not what it is. But did I not detox enough? Again,
you don't have full control over your ability to detox. You're just trying to support your detox
pathways. That's why after your 48 hours, when you try to get the chemo out of you, you're doing
coffee enemas. You're doing castoropax. You're supporting your liver detox pathways with
different supplements. You do everything you possibly can. It doesn't mean that you're going to
triple your detox pathway, the rate of detoxification by doing x, y and z. There's no way
that you can physically measure those things. You see the outcomes of our lack or ability or
disability and detoxifying. In this case, this would be one of them. But you just do your best
you possibly can. There's no magic thing that's going to make this all go away. So you just
continue to do the best thing you possibly can. Increase your ion pro waves to a daily. Increase your
coffee enemas. If you asked this question of max gerson 50 years ago, he'd say you should be doing
five coffee enemas a day. If you're really seeing an inability to detoxify. So everybody has a
different rate of detoxification that is often as almost always beyond your control. So you just try
to do your best to help stimulate that. So increase the number of coffee enemas would be a big
thing to do. That's your second question. Okay, the questions that came in. I got
iliac biopsy back, say progressive high grade philocular lymphoma. I am on my second
21 days with Artemisidine. Any thoughts to get this under control?
No, I think we just did. If I remember correctly, we just did a new cheek swab on you. Not very
long ago, when you started on that Artemisidine protocol, I don't know in the last cheek swab is,
if it was over 30 days ago, we could do another cheek swab and reassess some of those things.
And reassess your right frequency. So you're going to set another cheek swab at that.
Having a problem with my right machine, the ion pro wave works, no problem with the bulb is totally
dead and does not light it all. Okay, call right for they want me to send in the bulb and the
right machine. Have you seen this happen? How long do you think it'll take to get my right back?
So if the bulb is totally dead and it won't light it all, you could have just a problem with the bulb.
I don't know enough about the internal component set to know if the bulb programs would
not work if the ion pro wave, it seems like if the ion pro waves work, it's not the machine.
It would be the bulb. That's my fault.
But yeah, we've had people have problems with the bulb. Typically it has to do with like they trip
over the cord or something like that and pull the cord out at the glass tube itself
or the solder broke and then the bulb's not going to work. So you're not getting any frequencies.
Sure, when we first started with Turai, 12, 15 years ago, we had different issues that were
corrected and never happened again. That's probably the possibility. I would definitely send it
in as fast as possible. Typically they'll fix it that same day or the next day and send it back to you.
So it's usually a pretty quick turn around. They better really good about that even with
underdued management. They've been really good at it.
Dr. Cutters, what do you know about C60 for mitochondrial health? I have heard that it raises formal
levels and it's safe for breast cancer. It does seem that when I take your greens first by tumor
bleeds more, it doesn't cause the blood to be thinner. So the answer to this one first, the greens
first can cause it because it doesn't have a lot of different herbs in it. So if that's the case,
I would just stop that greens first or just cut your dose right down. The C60, I'm not a super
big fan on increasing mitochondrial function with cancer patients because you could also increase
the mitochondrial function of the cancer cell itself. So the mitochondria is the organelle within
the cell that you make energy. That's the main function of the mitochondria. It also has some DNA
components in it. But the main function of the mitochondria as we know it today is to make ATP.
And ATP is what runs the cell and runs all your cells. And you know, increasing mitochondrial health
and cancer patients is often thrown upon in the alternative community because you are, you know,
also increasing mitochondrial health in cancer cells. That's at least one line of thought. Remember with
dealing with cancer, there's often multiple lines of thought. Just like, you know, my line of thought
is not to use a lot of high amounts of glutamine when you have cancer because like, question earlier,
because it could increase growth. That's the whole idea of glutamine. But there's other alternative
doctors that do that that use glutamine. So it's just, you know, you have to, you know, do your best
research and kind of trust your gut on some of these things too. But I am, you know, I've studied C60
a number of years ago. When it first came out, there's a book, had some information about it. I got
the book. I just felt like that was the right thing to do with cancer. Can we use our right programming
without upgrading to 6.2 or 6.4? What is the benefit? Yes, please watch that video. That will answer
that question. With my last cheek swab, you added a number of supplements to my list. After I take them,
I often get blurry eyes and sometimes a headache. Any suggestions. I am doing liver pack every day too.
I would say make sure number one, you're taking these with food and maybe try to break them up a little
bit more. It also concerns me when a person says they have a reaction to a supplement that there is
not at least the possibility that their reaction is not to the supplement, but to the capsule.
So if you would try to open the capsules, I can't remember what I added to your list, but if you try
to open the capsules, if they are capsules, they do away with the capsule and just put that into a
shaker, something sprinkled out of your food, something like that. Try that and see if that makes a
difference. There is, it's not an uncommon thing that people can have a sensitivity to the
components of the capsule door. Is it an uncommon thing that people can actually have antibodies
to the gelatin that can be in capsules, even natural capsules, like the ones we have?
People from Puerto Rico and other Caribbean islands do boil sourcing leaves to make some tea.
I have heard that. Thank you for that. What are your thoughts about oxalates?
Well, oxalates are a bigger problem if you have a lot of defects on your oxalate detoxification gene.
So people that have a lot of defects on that, oxalates become a bigger problem, can't get rid of them.
They can form stones and cause kidney stones and other stones. But even someone who doesn't have
any issues on their, remember, your genes are just a picture. They're just a photograph of
possibilities. So a person, let's say, have zero defects, single or double-elgy defects on any
unemory single oxalate gene. They're perfectly clean. And they could get a kidney stone. Why is that?
Because it doesn't lead just because you don't have defects that you still don't have issues with
detoxifying, not just oxalates, but other things. So if you don't detoxify oxalates very well,
they can build up with your kidneys and they can cause stones in other places too. So oxalates can
be an issue, but it's like everything with moderation. So with some people, though, especially
people that have defects, they can be highly sensitive to oxalates and don't feel health
when they consume foods with a greater amount of oxalates. So again, just kind of test yourself,
boy, do I feel worse when I eat rhubarb? Yes, I do. Okay, well, maybe you have oxalate issues.
No, I don't at all. Well, maybe you don't have oxalate issues, even if you do have defects, maybe
detoxing them very well. Remember detoxification is a fluid flow of this river going through you.
It doesn't mean that just because I have docs detox issues today that I might not have them tomorrow.
It's it's constantly flowing. This river is flowing. So you're doing everything you can to keep
this this river moving at a rate that's acceptable to get rid of poisons that you're exposed to.
Even things that are in foods that are good for us. So you just keep working on that river to
get things out of your body that you don't want. What do you think about low dose chemotherapy?
Well, low dose chemotherapy can be very beneficial for people, especially if they're sensitive
to higher dose chemotherapy. You know, some people go through regular chemotherapy and don't have
a lot of issues. Some people just have a lot of issues and the people that do have a lot of issues
with chemotherapy usually are people that just have, you know, issues with their detoxification.
They just don't detoxify very well. The better what it is. So then using low dose chemotherapy
can be better, but it has its negative things too. So, you know, low dose chemotherapy typically
if you use a lot more dosage, meaning that so that is you get 10% of the dose of regular
chemotherapy usually, but you have to take more of the doses themselves. Another negative is that you
typically have to move to wherever you can get the application because you're there for three to
six months going through this therapy. So it's not like you can fly in and out, you know, on a
regular basis to do it. That can be a negative as far as lifestyle issues. And then it's still
chemotherapy. So if the chemotherapy isn't really going to work for your cancer, then the low dose
chemotherapy isn't going to work for your cancer either. And there's only a percentage of people
that chemotherapy isn't even going to work for your cancer. So I mean, if it's not going to, if regular
chemotherapy isn't going to work for me, then low dose chemotherapy isn't going to work for me either. So
what do you think about the work of Nisha Winters? I think this is
the work of care oncology type things. If I remember correctly, she's the one who
used who wrote the book of starving your cancer and uses different drugs off-label drugs. So she's
all into off-label those. We have some people that are doing that if I'm correct there. Sorry if
they're not. We have some people that are doing off-label drugs to help with their cancer. Met
form. And to me makes maybe the most sense because you're really reducing your glucose levels.
But I don't, she recommends docs cycling. And she's, you know, what I, if this is the same person,
I really like her because she doesn't. She takes a very rational approach to it.
Meeting that she's not claiming, making claims that aren't really honest. So I appreciate that. So
we have a lot of people that are doing some of those things. And they think that they're really
helping them. So Zoom liked out while you're answering my question about that rash. Would you mind?
Well, if you could just listen to this again. I'd appreciate that. I noticed the clear talks was
lumbar has lumbar kinase in it. I'm supposed to. Am I supposed to take that three per day and I
empty stomach? If I didn't tell you to put it up, if I don't, you don't have to, if you're asking
if you have to take lumbar kinase on empty stomach, the answer is no. And do you have to, if I told
you to take clear talks in empty stomach, then the answer is yes. So, but a person does not, if
you're taking lumbar kinase by itself, you don't have to take that empty stomach. Does the effect
of ketruda immunotherapy on the immune system wear off or stop after time on its own? That's a good
question. And the answer is yes, most always. I've at least what we've seen. So the negative effects of
immunotherapy can lead to inflammatory responses in the body. And it does wear off over time.
So immunotherapy only has, you know, if I get anything in your body, you are detoxed. It has a half
life in your body and it'll disappear over a period of time. That's why it's re-administered every three
weeks. And so it's, it's, it's, it will dissipate and you'll have, it doesn't leave, it can
leave lasting damage to a person, but it doesn't have that same lasting effect. It doesn't block the
receptor site on T cells because that's what immunotherapy does. It doesn't do that forever. So yes,
I feel very dry now inside and out. I drink about three quarts of water a day. Should I be
doing, taking something different to lubricate my body? Well, fats can be helpful for that,
getting good fats that can be helpful for that dry down feeling that can be helpful for the skin
issues that we talked about, increasing good fats, tallow type fats, which are animal fats,
which I know are, you know, bad things in today's society, but, you know, our ancestors, you know,
ate, you know, lard on a regular basis. And, you know, there's, there's people groups that eat that
on a regular basis and eat whale blubber as their main source of food and live long and happy
likes. So it is not fat that's causing arterial sclerosis. And so increasing good fats might be
helpful in different types of good fats. I have a section of paritoils in my book, but getting some good
omega-3 fats will be helpful consuming coconut oil, consuming animal fats can be helpful.
National Winters is all about the metabolic approach to cancer. Oh, okay. Nasha Winters is a protege
of the sig freed. And he talks about the metabolic approach to cancer, which is,
uh, Jay McCullough, thank you for how to start with cancer. Nasha Winters is, uh,
also the missile toe book and the metabolic approach. Thank you. The metabolic approach, I think,
is tied to Dr. Sinkfried's book on the ketogenic approach to cancer. So, um, yeah, I'm all in favor of
a ketogenic approach to cancer is if, like we talked about so many times, is that you don't
hug up on trying to get into ketosis and you're just trying to get your glucose levels down. So,
there's numerous studies going on right now that are showing that it's not important to get into
ketosis. It's just important to try to get your glucose levels down. And again, that only really
works for a percentage of people, because it's only a percentage of people that their cancer is
directly 100% fan off of the glycolysis pathway and not off of glutamine. So, you know,
know that in cancer is always trying to change its fuel source. So, you know, I've had people go,
if full ketosis and reverse their brain cancer, then also the brain cancer comes back with the
vengeance even though they've stayed on a fairly strong ketogenic diet. Why is that? Because the
cancer is changing its fuel source so that they have to change their diet. So, you have to be willing,
I think, and preach this forever to be pliable, to be, to change your approach when it's not going
in the right direction. It doesn't mean that your last approach was wrong. It just means that
cancer is constantly trying to change its fuel source. I missed a question back here. Have you heard
of nicotine for long COVID? No, I don't think I have. I try to think it brings a bell, but I don't,
I don't, I've written some stuff about long COVID, but I think I wrote any more nicotine.
If an increasing mitochondrial function could also increase the function of cancer cells,
I'm wondering about the efficacy of the ketogenic diet since they're also supposed to need to
increase mitochondrial function. Um, yeah, well, maybe that's why it doesn't work for some people.
There's just, there's just, as you're, it's interesting, I think, the more you learn,
the more you realize how complex our body is, or you could say, the more you learn, the more you
realize just how stupid you are. I get that feeling every single thing. So, but in a nice way,
the more you learn, the more you realize that really, there's just so much information. And, you know,
I think it's, that's why I've always been saying that it's really wrong to take dogmatic
stances. Um, you know, again, going back to the question about the C-60 where some, or I made
a statement that maybe was a little too dogmatic, that I've not been in favor of, you know, being,
I've been being careful about, um, you know, increasing mitochondrial function for cancer patients,
but the truth is, is that maybe if a person isn't doing well and doing C-60 increasing the mitochondrial
function of your healthy cells is what can knock out the cancer cells. So, um, you know, if you're,
if anybody is looking for me to give them the magic answers, I think the more you go listen to these
soon calls, you realize that I, nor does anyone have the magic answers. And I think, and I hope that
you're realizing, when you read books about other written by doctors that are basically kind of
egotistically professing that they have magic answers, probably haven't seen a lot of cancer patients.
Um, because it's one of the things I remember learning from Dr. Gonzalez who I just respected so
highly, is that he never pretended to have that. And he was just always open-minded. Um, and, you know,
and, and because he was working so hard on trying to help cancer patients, and that's all he saw
in his practice was cancer patients. Matter of fact, he was still alive when Sigfried came out with his
book on the metabolic approach to cancer, and his critique of it to me was that it's interesting that
this scientist is saying that everybody with cancer should go on a ketogenic diet. When this
scientist, he only literally, if you go back and read his book, he has the example of one cancer
patient in the book, which had with the person had smoldering multiple myeloma, which smoldering
multiple myeloma, you know, can smolder for 10 years. You can't use that as a, as a, as your one
example of a ketogenic helping a cancer patient with the ketogenic diet. Again, this doctor who
wrote the book brilliant, as he was understanding metabolic pathways is brilliant as he did.
He doesn't treat cancer patients. So he had one example in his book. So always when you read
information, when you read data, when you read books, you know, um, you're going to get the most
honest answers from practitioners who are seeing people on a daily basis that have cancer.
And I think if you see people on a daily basis, you realize what way we're beautifully for one person
doesn't work at all for another person. You have to be willing to change course and tweak things
and and and be open minded to as many things as possible. And, uh, and that's so dogmatic
position. So, you know, I'm open to it. If you feel like God's leading you in any way, and I've said
this over and over again, if God's leading you to do something that by all means, you need to be
obedient to that more than your obedient to anything else. So, um, I preach, I just think all of our
patients are just so you guys are studying and learning. And I just, but I learned just more from you
guys than you guys do for me. I'm still pretty diabetic, even though I have given up grades, I am
taking the supplements to suggest any other suggestions. And we talked about this, you know, sometimes
are again, we don't fit into this mold of we're going to, you know, go on a ketogenic like diet,
which you've basically been on and and have our body drop into a pre ketone burning state or a
ketone burning state and full ketosis. It just doesn't always work that way. So, um, we just
got to be okay with it not working that way and our glucose stayed up at, you know, 98, but I can't
figure out why because I don't eat any carbohydrates. It's just the way it is and you can't really make
those make that happen anymore than you are. It's certainly going out of faster doing some sort of
modified as to adopt me in your best interest at this point. So, we don't want to do that. You
remember one of the worst things you can do is quit yourself in a state of cacasia where you're losing
weight and you're way under weight. That's just not healthy for your healthy cells. So again, sometimes
doing things that are good for your healthy cells that seemingly all this might help feed a cancer cell
back to be careful. But if it's good for your healthy cells, sometimes that's the best thing for
a person. So, um, but I'll tell you, you know, like I said last week over and over. This is one of the
most important things is what goes on between your ears, your stress levels, your anxiety over your
diet over your supplements over your cancer is the most critical factor. In my opinion, I was interviewed
for something was a couple months ago and somebody said, well, what's the most critical factor in
helping somebody stop cancer? And it's just like it just came out immediately, which was it's what
goes on in your head. So, I believe in my life that, you know, God used cancer to help change, you know,
that that's my spiritual walk and what goes on in my head and myself talk. It's so important to take
that that role of, you know what? I'm going to do everything I can and I'm not going to freak out
about anything, including the results. And if God wants me to change something, He's just going to have
to, you know, get me over the head sometimes, sometimes He certainly does that. But I need to listen
and I need to be good at listening to that still still small voice in the Holy Spirit in my life so
He can just tell me what to do. But I'm not going to fret, I'm not going to worry, I'm not going to,
you know, because then I'm really making an idol out of my diet and my blood test and my results
and regardless that's not God's purpose in my life. And it's not bringing me joy and it's not,
you know, helping me fulfill any purpose and why God has me stay alive. He's got me here alive,
it's to serve others and I'm doing no good serving others by being consumed with myself.
So that's a work in progress and that's the fight that we're called to fight, that good fight,
that we're called to fight, is the fight against our flesh and to make sure that we are serving God,
the way we're supposed to be serving Him and not be too self-consumed at least for myself.
And that's a struggle. It's a struggle for a lot of us, but certainly my struggle and it's when
then you just keep fighting that fight. All right, so please watch the video on the site about the
true life updates. You do not have to do the updates, you can stay running your 6.0 software.
There's no reason for you to do the update, but there is going to probably come a time where
you're going to have to do the update. If you have, if you, that scares you a little bit,
us do the update, send it back to us and we'll do the update for it.
If, but there's certainly no reason that you have to do the 6.4 update. But if you do contact true
life and you're having trouble with the right, they're going to tell you you have to do, they're not
going to serve us anything below 6.4. So they will make you do the 6.4 update. So yeah, if you're doing
well and you can do it without your your right for a couple days, we'll then send it back to us and
we'll do the update for you. Or if you're pretty computer savvy, you can follow these handy,
handy instructions that I put right on the website and you can do the update by yourself and you
can have this all done in 15 minutes. So it's up to you. So watch the video and I will give you
some more hints. All right, that being said, know that I'm praying for all you guys and keep up the
good fight and and you will be rewarded. Know that I love you all and we're constantly praying for
all of you. Till next week.